not remark not normally I prepare a you
know a written text but since I it's
just written two nights ago with sleepy
they got these compilations of my note
here and there and it's put in one piece
of paper that I would like to deliver it
now first of all let me thanks to
Professor say USB LAN for Sherrington
for kind introductions and it is an
honor for me to be in this prestigious
university everybody knows what you know
what L is and whenever I speak at
universities I have related to remember
that I am a graduate student myself few
people knows this but I am currently
working on my PhD thesis with the
Australian National University so you
are not talking not to the bathroom
we're talking to students around and you
know it make me nervous because I'm
talking in front of prophets right but
why I'm going to Canberra because I'm
sure that I cannot be accepted here the
year businessman quick to note the
economic science China's economy grew by
more than eleven percent as you know in
the third quarter of this year and Viet
Nam's economy grew by over eight percent
the same period yesterday the fourth
annual China ASEAN Expo ended bringing
attention back to the region school of
ASEAN China free trade area by 2010
politically newspaper headlines revealed
at the science of change negotiations on
the Korean Peninsula encouraging the
upcoming Olympic highlight
Chinese rice a new regional initiatives
are shipping is Asian multi lateral isms
and next month
Indonesia will host a major United
Nations conventions addressing not the
source of genes the climate the current
context of international relations in
East Asia then is a deep change
nevertheless I see several trend with
time I believe that Indonesia will not
only grow more important but Indonesians
and US relations will grow more
important with it already
Indonesia's profile is rising its
economy is the largest in Southeast Asia
with a promising specific indicators the
religions of its citizens has placed it
at the center of global Madrid Network
and its democratic reform as you all
know has given it uniquely
strong foundations on which to build its
future in all of these areas its economy
its majority religions and its Riven
Indonesia is growing more important when
I speak to an analyst some Express
surprised at this conclusion I have to
remind them that Indonesia of my country
can no longer be measured with a ruler
calibrated in 1998 or prior to that
Indonesia has recovered from the
turbulence of those years today we need
to look forward the country's future not
its pass economically for instance the
future is promising at a macro level GDP
growth has increased every year since
2001 this year the government expect to
see five point eight to six percent
growth
and if you recall in 1997 or 1998 one
can never think of what we are achieving
today at that point in time our economy
contracted to minus 13 and in only less
than a decade with all the challenges
that we faced with all the challenges
that have to be responded by our people
such as natural disaster man-made
disaster forest fire and all those kind
of challenges that we have overcome and
ethnics thrives in different part of
Indonesia occurred in between 1998 and
till today then the one can hardly find
that Indonesia today is not those that
we expect to be in during in 1998 when
we change and when we start to reform
every respect people's life
no speaking but not economic indicators
specific indicators are strong as well
the bang of Indonesia lowered its
interest rate by 3 percent in 2006 and
it looks ready to bring it down to 8% by
next year after period of instability
during the Asian financial crisis
inflation has stabilized at six point
six percent the country's reserve have
grown by billions its credit rating has
improved and the Jakarta
stock exchange grew by about 30 percent
according to my note never in the
Indonesian history that we can be able
to accumulate well of course this is
small but it is a shipment an accumulate
foreign currency reserve up to around 51
or 52 billion Laster in the past we was
good if we could reach the level of
around 30 to 35 but this is what we have
secured in 2006 our export reached the
level of 100 and so Pastner surpassed
the level of 100 billion USDollar
2006 when and week actually expect that
we can get somewhat some something are
wrong 100 billion to 110 billion by this
year amid is easy as change social
factors will also affect Denisha within
what some see as a debate within Islam
Indonesia is at the center of a growing
in global moderate Muslim network the
government of Indonesia is the country's
two leadings it some organizations and
wide array of Indonesian civil society
groups have explicitly condemn violence
as Indonesia moves into the future its
leaders will remain committed to keeping
aslam as a religions of peace and
devotion not one of violence and
intolerance in this role Indonesia is
unique the religions history in the
people echo gives it a tolerant and
understanding character and with about
200 millions believers
Indonesia is home to as many Muslims as
the entire Middle East as Muslims around
the world determine the future course of
Islam many will look to Indonesia in
addition to its economic growth and
religious character Indonesia's
democratic reform will also increase it
cetera the same reforms that seem
difficult today are building a stronger
base for tomorrow as timís castles and
click Kearney noted recently in the
Washington Post democratic reform is a
better of auditions for long term
stability than authoritarian government
this is lessons all Indonesians life
1998 remember as our leaders invests in
steady reform today continue sir will
see its importance rise tomorrow but
we're all lists our Indonesian US
relations today
Indonesian US relations a strong
President Bush has called Indonesia
vital friend and strategic partner the
letter that he sent to Indonesia
ambassador when myself where I submitted
my credential contain such a note that
Indonesia was called as vital friend in
strategic manner
Secretary Rice has echoed this fuse
describing our relations as a tremendous
partnership and looking ahead now I
believe this partnership will grow
stronger it's true that a changing East
Asia is full of us uncertainty but our
leaders brief enough to see opportunity
that change through engagement trade and
values Indonesia and United States are
drawing closer together
Indonesia is really engaging the world
earlier today we assumed the rotating
presidency of the United Nations
Security Council next month it will host
offer three offered 30,000 international
delegates to the UN Framework Convention
on Climate Change in Bali and we also
engage in the Muslim world last year
Indonesia contributed soldier to UN
peacekeeping operations in Lebanon Ron
1,100 Indonesian soldier know being
deployed in the particular area of the
world and we hosted reconciliations
dialogues about Hilux the country
remains an active member of the
organization's of Islamic Conference and
late last month
Indonesia hosted the first ever visits
of Palestinian President to the
archipelago together in the
neasha and united states could harness
this engagement to secure the best
long-term solutions to terrorism and
empowering the moderates and this is one
of the opportunities that opportunity
lies with trade businessmen are drawing
our countries closer together since 2003
bellator trade has grown by efforts 1.5
billion each year in 2005 American
foreign direct investment total nine
point nine billion companies as diverse
as Starbucks kept Mars I&C F establish
the major operations there in Indonesia
in term of trade by the year of 2006 we
secured the level of from sixteen point
four billion US dollar and only since
January to June this year we have
already accumulated some nine point
eight billion u.s. dollars so if it come
to the end of this year we might expect
that the trade volume between Indonesia
and us vice-versa will reach the level
of hopefully around 20 billion yesterday
as I said Starbuck gaps and all those
operates in Indonesia but more than
coffee clothes and chocolate the
potential of energy is particularly high
the United States is the world's largest
energy consumer if I'm not mistaken new
consumer on eighteen point five million
u.s. dollar per day in Indonesia is the
place where you can still find something
to be tapped and this is what one
element that we may use it to cement the
relations or in any case we might
probably get this kind of natural
resource become an element for us to
diapers
recent government survey place in
Tunisia as crude oil reserve at eight
point six billion barrels
according to 2006 report only 22 of an
estimated 60 oil persons have been
extensively explored and Indonesia
remains the top exporter of liquefied
natural gas and today as global LNG
prices have doubled over the past three
years this is an opportunity for
American companies lastly of course
Indonesia in United States remain bound
by values our culture traditions and
histories are different but we are tied
by Democratic respect for pluralism for
representative government for
enterprises and for education this is
reflected in each country's national
motto our bhinneka tunggal iike or unity
in diversity it's very similar to your e
pluribus unum or out of many one and
this affinity is also reflected in
practice in 2003 for instance President
Bush introduced some 150 million
education initiative for Indonesia
American NGOs have contributed to the
rapid expansions of Indonesia civil
society and at personal level American
tourism to Indonesia is on the rise in
2005 we will come over 150,000 American
visitors as values continue to build
government and Gon personal bridges the
relationship between Indonesia and
United States will only grow stronger
the recent history of Indonesian u.s.
relations is remarkable as with East
Asia it is a story of change 10 year ago
my country was under at the Rotarians
rule suffering from u.s. sanction
today Indonesia's the world the third
largest democracy far from sanctions
United States no 6 our partnership
across matters of engagement trade and
values is a sea ice change have created
new opportunities for Indonesia and the
u.s. to
closer as a person who are designed to
represent my country I've been given
these areas my full attention I'm often
asked to speak about international
affairs and often I am asked why I feel
Indonesian US relations are so important
to me the answer is simple between
Indonesia and the US is a partnership
that breaks the rules for our it's not a
class of civilization but cooperations
between civilizations our culture's are
different many of our perspectives are
different but ahead
the shared future and from where I stand
the future looks bright indeed thank you
very much sure sure for sure yes yes sir
thank you very much
may I take probably two more questions
before I give my answer yes sir thank
you thank you very much one more
questions please yes sir
yes thank you
first questions the role of military in
the domestic politics
I cannot imagine Indonesian military
take their role as in the past the day
the fact that we have vibrant press we
have free society we have
non-governmental organizations we have
civil sauce very strong civil society
and well I have claimed that Indonesia
has the third largest democracy the
military themselves have already left
the politics domestic politics by
lifting the representations in the
parliaments and rule in term of
representations is being defined by
civilian through the representations in
the parliaments and with the support of
the civil society
now with this I cannot imagine the
military in Indonesia can wreak in what
they have in the past this I think I'm
speaking in terror no let me put it into
a more specific
issue of what you said in Timor for
instance saying that the military began
the presence trying to as a pro click
and put it as try to regain the role in
the past or their and their position in
the past I do not know but with the
number of military active in Indonesia
only but probably less than less than
four hundred thousands and spread offer
an area as fast as United States can
they still dominate the country I don't
think so because with the small number
that we have secondly also as I said in
democracy I don't think that there is
any longer a place for them to play
politics or otherwise people will put it
in headlines everywhere and with that I
don't think that they can sustain
they're trying to regain what I said as
the position in the past so this is
another general overview of what the
military have in in my view and the
military himself their South they have
committed very strongly in what they
said as placing military and democracy
as a reform process that is going on
since nineteen ninety eight and thirty
day so with this I cannot imagine that
the military can return to what their
positions prior to the reform took place
in 1998 and West Papua if we talk about
West Papua today it is not West Papua
that we might imagine in the past the
special autonomy law the law number 21
has been promulgated to governor's has
been elected
freely by their people and several head
of agencies has also been elected freely
through various kind of elections
process very transparent and accountable
and only for our up one friends to use
the opportunity of 12.16 trillion rupiah
that is allocated for them to spend in
2006 never in the history of Indonesia
that such huge amount of fun being
provided for Papua for them to manage
why I'm speaking about their own
management because probably I can speak
for 80 percents of officials occupying
different level or different layer of
bureaucracy in Papua are no pop one so
it is only for the pop one people to use
this as an opportunity and of course it
should also been placed in the context
of accountability in term of how the
government spends the fun so first I
don't think that military can be in
Papua like in the past because then the
civil society which also have their role
to criticize this this this if at all
there is an operations of the DNA will
become harder for this military to
operate there and at the same time when
we talk about how pop one can you don't
have the opportunity to build their own
areas then the amount of funded I said
so that come to around 1.4 billion US
dollar 1.4 billion u.s. only for about
2.5 million people so we can imagine if
they cannot use this this Essen SS in
opportunity and and it's not it's not
the fault of anyone but they fall
of those who am in the bureaucracy to
compare to compare action in West Papua
thing is to kind of different things
there have been armed conflict in Aceh
throughout years since 76 until nineteen
until 2005 but there is no such a
conflict in Papua and the fact that we
are talking about how to to give an
opportunity to pursue a welfare with
this funding and talking about IJ that
and where I'm conflicting for I think we
are talking about two different things
and the solutions for the two difference
whattcha we have secured the peace
through a peace agreement in Helsinki
and I do know whether for Papua we need
to sign an agreement with whom who are
going to represent Papua because such a
guy first such a diverse groups access
in Papua and after all with the
elections of the two governors with
elections of six or seven regions his
head
I think pop wise we are represented by
buying their own leaders and to pursue
their welfare without any need to to
seek a peaceful solutions with anyone
because there is no I'm conflicting
there no on the force fire we establish
cooperation with neighboring countries
we also part of ASEAN
effort to address case such as that
happen in Sumatra forest file and on
illegal logging
of course the rule of law is no being at
least we try to we try to uphold the
principle of rule of law in addressing
the issue of illegal logging but more
than that the role of civil society the
role of our free press and the role of
those that have a concern about issue of
local logging have been able to be
together with the government to address
the issue of illegal logging by
implementation so by enforcing the law
so this I think very general but this is
what we have been doing in Riau province
for instance recently there has been a
very strong case of how the police tried
the best to enforce the law even this
group of police men and the police
establishments know in in a not not in a
very good resistance with Minister of
Forestry for they have their own
principle to uphold the law
and so this I think more other things
what we have been doing in terms of
addressing the questions of illegal
logging concerning is Timor I think it's
wrong to perceive Indonesia today in
their listen with a steam or bringing
the legacy of the past because there
have been completely changed
relations sip sip of religions have
completely changed what is the moral is
no doing is their own domestic affairs
that we do not meddle with them and we
helping EC more in many occasions in
many in different areas we work very
closely with its tomorrow when they seek
membership to ascend the East Asian
Nations depends who these Asian Nations
know they are in the process of applying
the membership of shannon already been
admitted as part of the dialogue partner
so the relations is in a good shape and
we are trying as best as we can to help
them consolidate their own business
their own affairs and with that we ready
only to help in every respect
ffft with us to do so so I think
relations was excellent any other
questions please yes from this side lady
yes
sure oh yeah
thank you very much the issue of draft
bill on anti-pornography has been with
Department since 2001 I think it's only
been years yes
with the upcoming elections I believe
that well I'm a very very true believer
of pluralism Indonesia's society are
those that are super allistic that will
not allow such a law to be adopted by
the Parliament if you look at the
present representations in the
parliament I think those that come from
nationalist peace political parties does
that come from secular I must associate
from secular persuasions far over the
dose that piss their positions in term
of this drug bill in the parliament so I
don't want to give you an exact
calculations of who going to foot
forward but I am you know a true
believer of this pluralism and tourism
will become the backbone for the you
know for the decision path Parliament to
do a talk or not adopting the bill and
if it is going to be if there is going
to be a bill on this on this particular
areas anti-pornography
then this will be diluted in such a way
that it will allow the performing art be
given a their life not going to be
hindrance hindered by by law like but
some people want it to be I cannot
imagine that people in Bali canned you
know allow this kind of
you know of bill to pass if it contains
the prohibitions of those who perform
art being seen as pornography
so first pluralism second the domestic
political constellations in term of who
represents what and I believe that
political parties that base their
ideology on nationalism rather than
religions will become will still be
implementing dominant positions and then
thirdly I believe that there will be
still process but if it is going to be
if there will be a draft bill passed
then this will become very very loose
and can accommodate every aspirations
for performing art not to be hindered by
such canopy yeah yes please sir your bit
blue with blue you you you rest before
to talk about action against a
particular country against a sovereign
state then we are talking about United
Nations see what the Consul only of
course we cannot sanction any country's
peace on a unilateral act effectively
because you may have seen sanction
against Iran for instance already in yes
but still you know they pursue their you
know their interest in building I do
know whether this is peaceful or and not
peaceful nuclear facilities so Indonesia
wanted to see every nations especially
to the neighboring state to push
stronger pressure this is a little bit
early can could be seen as a sanction
against such a country because bringing
it to the context of imposing sanctions
without the involvement of neighboring
countries I think will not be easy for
for for us to change the the situations
in Myanmar secondly Indonesia operates
in the context of ASEAN in dealing with
Miyama in different layers of ASEAN para
cracy that is from summit tone to
Minister meeting down to senior official
talent to TG level in every occasions we
express our concern we press strong
pressure against Miami so this I think
it's one of the way that we would like
Myanmar to change so first is through
the neighbouring countries pressors what
I mean is China and India because these
two big countries have very strong
influence to tomiyama and then Indonesia
to get with ASEAN will continue to to to
press ahead with ideas of roadmap that
they'd already been that they already
promised and in the Security Council as
member of the super constant we would
like very much to cooperate with other
other members to exert pressure in
Miyama and with the appointment of
special envoy by the secretary-general I
think this is one of the way on how the
international community Khan connects
what we risk with what messages in in
memoir
thank you yes sir
thank you
well let me distance myself with police
making process and put myself in
positions as an observer Indonesia have
been very long lives of India in the
non-aligned movement that I think need
to be revisited today because by by by
by feeling of very close to India as
member and/or a founder even fonder of
nonviolent movement we are somewhat
being blinded by what is going on Adam
of the military the growth of the
military The Grocer India s military
power so we haven't yet come to that
states of assessing the relations with
India
using the military elements in the
religions as part of our assessment so
this very frank assessment what is going
on because we have we have to
comfortable being you know being partner
of India and the moon align movement
without seeing that something is
changing when we talk about the Malacca
Strait for instance in different
questions we differs with them on how to
secure the the this line of navigations
so it's time I think for Indonesia to
get into a more 16 and in seeing what is
happening in term of India it's been
growing as military power we haven't yet
come to that state thank you
yes ladies
yeah we base our positions but on Israel
on the Indonesia's constitutions the
first paragraph of the preamble of the
concision said that Indonesia is peace
on the belief that my culinary systems
have to be renounce so we are seeing
with questions of Palestine and aside
from that particular angles there is
that there is still a group of people
that have been caught yet their
independence so we are trying to help
alleviate these situations from from
from from the very beginning of these
office I'll crop top in 1949 until today
from this piece on this bid on these
convictions that there is still group of
people that haven't yet got their
independence and our constitutions
mandated the state mandated Indonesia to
help renounce Colonel Colonel
colonialism so we see this particular
issue from this particular from from
from from from this and know at when we
in the States and where there are number
of group of power holder in Palestine
like Hamas and Fatah and all those we
would like to work with them in term of
persuading them to use as best as they
can to resort to non-violence in and
finding real solutions and the questions
of Israel
so peace on this two basic tenets of our
thinking that is the Constitution's and
secondly that no one should resort to
violence in finding solutions we are
working closely with Palestine to
try to help seeking resolutions in this
issue yes yes please
thank you
well we of the belief that Papua is part
of West India part of that colony so
when actually the power up in
transferred into the independent country
of Indonesia Papua would have been
within three settings from the very
beginning but only because our friend
the touch it's stronger than Indonesia
in term of their position in the
international politics at that time the
whole Papua and only with the 1969
referendum that we have Papua period us
which actually should have been with us
since from the very beginning of
dependence of Indonesia so independence
of Papua Indonesia is no questions but
only for us to know how to provide as
best as we can welfare for our friends
in in in that area so there will never
any any one in Indonesia who think that
Papua become independent country peace
on at least based on at least what I
said that if this if a colonial power
left and the transfer of authority is
done to be transferred to the newly
independent state then the whole
territory of the colonial rule the color
master have to be transferred and we
have been
well in it is everything that we could
have been kind enough as to let the pop
one issues only soften in 1969 while in
fact from 1945 and 1949 when the whole
territory of in a former colony of Dutch
been transferred to Indonesia actually
Papa's would have been with Indonesia
thank you